paraíso fiscal para algunos y éxito
económico para otros lo cierto es que
Panamá un enclave vital para el
comercio mundial que ha registrado en
los últimos 15 años uno de los mayores
crecimientos económicos del mundo es un
país que está de moda
hoy buscamos conocerlo un poco mejor
Panamá es una franja de tierra de 75
mil kilómetros cuadrados bañada por el
mar caribe y el océano pacífico tiene
como países vecinos a costa rica y
colombia con una población ligeramente
superior a los tres millones y medio de
personas y un pib per cápita en paridad de poder adquisitivo de casi 20.000 euros
su economía está centrada
fundamentalmente en el sector servicios
explorado y colonizado por los
españoles en el siglo 16 tras la
independencia de las colonias americanas
Panamá unió su suerte a la de Colombia
y no fue hasta 1903 cuando finalmente
obtuvo su independencia, proceso en el
que contó con la inestimable ayuda de
los Estados Unidos que tenían como
objetivo construir y gestionar bajo su
soberanía el que sin duda el elemento
más famoso de este pequeño país
"el canal es una arteria vital hay
trabajo por hacer" con 80 kilómetros el
canal conecta y permite el paso de
barcos entre el océano atlántico y el
océano pacífico y desde su
inauguración en 1914 lo han cruzado
más de 700 mil buques convirtiéndose
así en uno de los enclaves más
importantes del comercio mundial cada
año le reporta gobierno panameño más
de 1.000 millones de euros en ingresos y
tras ocho años de intensas obras en el
que ha sido uno de los mayores proyectos de la
ingerían moderna y 5.000 millones de
euros de inversión, el próximo 26 de
junio se inaugurará la ampliación del
canal que tiene como objetivo duplicar
su capacidad y permitir el paso de los
barcos conocidos como post-panamax, barcos
de mayor dimensión que llegan a
transportar más de 13 mil contenedores
cada uno.  Junto al canal el otro elemento
característico de Panamá es que es uno
de los pocos países del mundo que no
tiene banco central. Así como lo escuchais,
en Panamá tanto los tipos de interés
como los niveles del dinero y crédito
de la economía se determinan por la libre
interacción entre oferentes y
demandantes de capital, quienes además
tienen pleno acceso a los mercados
internacionales, sin ningún tipo de
restricción. Además, como en Panamá no
hay un banco emisor de moneda, la
economía de facto sea dolarizado con lo
cual ni ciudadanos ni empresas están
sujetos al riesgo cambiario, al riesgo
de los tipos de cambio de divisas
hay quien puede pensar que carecer de
banco central puede ser un origen de
muchos problemas o de inestabilidades
pero Panamá ha demostrado
todo lo contrario el hecho de carecer de
este organismo de planificación le ha
supuesto convertirse en una de las
macroeconomías más estables de todo el
mundo
de hecho es el único país de
latinoamérica que jamás ha conocido
colapso financiero alguno
la última crisis financiera la de 2008
la pasó con un crecimiento económico
envidiable sin que ninguno de sus
bancos tuviesen el mismo problema y hoy
pugna por ser la capital financiera de
latinoamerica. En Panamá operan más
de 90 bancos, más del doble que en
México y casi el triple de los que
operan en toda España "¿sabes como llaman
a eso los pobres?
las torres de la cocaína y a nuestros
85 bancos las lavanderías"
pero claro no podemos hablar de Panamá
ni de su sistema fiscal sin mencionar su
supuesta condición como paraíso fiscal
su reputación como tal data de hace
más de 100 años y la standar oil
registraba sus buques en este país para
permitirle al magnate john rockefeller
reducir su carga tributaria en los Estados
Unidos. Aunque sin duda la explosión como
supuesto paraíso fiscal llegó en la década
de los 80 "en los tiempos difíciles, quizá
en la época de Noriega la justicia de
los violentos" cuando de la mano de su
dictador Manuel Antonio Noriega,
Panamá se convirtió en el refugio del
dinero del narcotráfico, particularmente
del dinero del cártel de Medellín quien
liderado por Pablo Escobar conseguía
ganar cada año más de 4.000 millones
de euros
pero esta historia acabo en diciembre de
1989 cuando estados unidos invadió
panamá y condenó a noriega a pasar el
resto de sus días en cárceles y
centros penitenciaros de Estados Unidos
Francia y Panamá "es estrella que falta
en nuestra bandera señores
me parece que dios nos está dando una
segunda oportunidad" Pero, ¿por qué el
dinero escoge este país?¿Por qué el
dinero acude a panamá?
Fundamentalmente porque este país tiene
normativas que está tratan de salvaguardar
el secreto bancario y la confidencialidad en
las transacciones y por qué es uno de los
pocos países donde se pueden constituir
sociedades con la emisión de acciones
al portador
esto es que garantizan el anonimato de
sus propietarios
todo ello junto a las posibilidades
de su sistema bancario hacen de este país un
lugar ideal para quienes el mejor de los
casos tratan de huir de de regímenes
fiscales opresores y en el peor de ellos
quienes tratan de esconder el dinero de
actividades ilícitas
"bienvenidos a panamá casa blanca sin
héroes"
Pero, a pesar de ser un enclave
logístico y financiero destacado, Panamá
no es un país rico
es verdad que desde 1990 ha crecido
mucho, más de un 6 por ciento cada año
pero también es cierto que la pobreza
sigue siendo una lacra que afecta a más
del 20 por ciento la población y a más
del 10% en el caso de la pobreza extrema
pero ¿por qué ocurre todo esto?
principalmente por tres motivos el
primero de ellos
la economía de Panamá no es
precisamente libres, es verdad que hay
bajos impuestos pero también mucha
burocracia y además existen controles
de precios, los costes de contratación
no laborales son muy altos
el gasto público también es elevado y
las políticas de subsidios y
proteccionismo suelen ser más que
habituales "hay una horrible red de blanqueo
de dinero, tráfico de drogas y
corrupción"
el gobierno de Panamá se puede decir que es un
gobierno pro amiguetes más que un
gobierno progre mercado. Así, no es extraño
que en e índice de libertad económica
ocupe el puesto 66 y en el índice doing
business el puesto 69. Y todos
conocemos lo relacionado que estos índices
están con el nivel de riqueza de un país.
En segundo lugar en Panamá hay una oligarquía
que controla tanto el poder político
como el poder económico, buen ejemplo de
todo esto es el de Ramón Fonseca ,fundador
del conocidisimo bufete Mossack Fonseca, que
hasta hace unas pocas semanas además
era ministro consejero del gobierno y
presidente del primer partido político
del país y esto no es una excepción, es un
hecho habitual y en tercer lugar la
corrupción según el índice de transparencia
internacional de percepción de la
corrupción
panamá ocupa el puesto 71 y además
tiene un problema con la politización
de la justicia. Es verdad que no todo es
malo y en los últimos tiempos han logrado
muchos avances
tal vez el más destacado todos ellos
sea la declaración de la ciudad de Colón
como zona libre tratando de emular el
éxito que en el pasado iniciativas similares
tuvieron en hong kong o macao
vamos a ver cómo evoluciona este país
desde luego si apuesta por la
competitividad el potencial de panamá
le puede llevar a convertirse en la
singapor de latinoamerica.